bien entendu cette rencontre était
attendu à la lumière des récents
événements impliquant le vol dérouté par
les autorités biélorusses et ses
conséquences en termes de trafic aérien
et d'éventuelles sanctions au président
biélorusse s'est présenté face à son
homologue avec près de lui une mallette
qui d'après lui contiennent des
documents censés apporter des preuves à
la position de nice
alexandre loukachenko qui a au passage
accusé l'occident de chercher à
déstabiliser son pays à dirkou tine de
son côté a rappelé le précédent de
l'avion présidentiel bolivien qui en
2013 a été forcé de se poser à vienne
sous la pression des états unis de
crainte qu edward ce modèle se trouve à
bord je vous propose d'écouter les deux
hommes je vais vous présenter un certain
nombre de mois et vous allez voir ce qui
se passe cette semaine c'est une
tentative de et des salaires qu'ils
avaient détourné l'avion de président
bolivien bonfils c'est vrai c'est vrai
et est un tueur qui vous souvenez de
cela un avion qui dirigea vers sydney et
on a fait atterrir l'avion n'est
d'accord c'est votre droit se verront de
la faire il a donc été question de
l'actualité de ce vol dérouté donc mais
pas seulement
le développement des relations
bilatérales et de l'intégration des deux
pays étaient également au programme de
cette rencontre
d'ailleurs à ce sujet vladimir poutine a
fait l'éloge de résultats concrets du
rapprochement entre la russie et la
biélorussie